malgré la dégradation n'ont pas fait
depuis trois ans il ne lâche rien pas un
mot des auditions aussi brève que
décevante
nicolas zepeda parlera-t-il un jour son
arrivée à besançon
va-t-elle changer la donne qui est
nicolas zepeda nicolas zepeda est le
fils d'une riche famille du chili son
père est un cadre de movistar un géant
des télécoms
le jeune homme âgé de 29 ans est diplômé
en gestion des entreprises
il a étudié au japon où il a rencontré
n'a rumi sur lui on sait peu de choses
sinon qu'en 2016 juste après sa rupture
avec l'étudiante japonaise il effectue
un séjour dans une clinique spécialisée
dans les troubles du comportement très
tôt nicolas zepeda beaucoup écrit sur
des blogs des histoires d'amour brisée
où prédomine la mêlant colère ceux qui
l'ont connu le décrivent comme très
intelligent sociable mais possessif
que lui reproche la justice française
nicolas zepeda est le seul suspect dans
cette affaire la justice française du
soupçon d'assassinât avec préméditation
et dissimulation de corps zepeda est
effectivement le dernier à avoir vu la
rue mis dans cette chambre 106 de la
cité universitaire de besançon
vers 3 heures du matin j'ai entendu des
cris d'angoissé assez fort assez dupe
irrégulier et
j'ai aussi entendu des mômes sous les
portes les meubles dans la nuit du 4 au
5 décembre 2016 zepeda a très
vraisemblablement étranglé la jeune
japonaise
les enquêteurs ont reconstitué son
emploi du temps minute par minute
il parle de lui comme d'un petit poucet
qui auraient malgré lui se met des
dizaines d' indices il considère qu'il
est clairement venu en france dans le
but de tuer n'a rumi quelle sera sa
ligne de défense
photo henri portes ou trois ans et demi
après les faits on ne sait toujours pas
où se trouve le corps donne à rémy
kurosaki sans cadavre la défense peut
facilement contesté l'accusation de
crime
nicolas zepeda a choisi comme avocate
une figure du barreau parisien
jacqueline laffont a défendu charles
pasqua alexandre benalla et plus
récemment nicolas sarkozy surnommé la
torpille use de procédure on ne sait pas
encore quelle carte elle jouera mais en
choisissant une avocate aussi au cap et
cepeda montrant qu'ils se projettent
dans le combat judiciaire avec des
moyens financiers importants